cheers darling cheers
um as you can tell i'm in the pool if
you're a fan of mariah carey you know
she likes to keep it festive and
fabulous i am festive and that's just
what she did on tuesday night you guys
aren't filming from my dad's side right
now are you darling turning a bleak
boring midday week into an all-out
moment it's over the top already sort of
top enough taking a dip in the pool with
full glam and a sequin dress to go live
on instagram hello darlings
it's a splash
you were wondering what a splash was
here it is
first of all do you like the ensemble
yes
yes we do oh thank you the ensemble a
bronze sparkly full-length body hugging
gown i like playing you know to play
dress up i'm trying to give mermaid
vibes i i i wasn't trying but i love the
pool and it's my favorite place and
i was gonna go in the hot tub but then i
thought i might start sweating and my
hair would change textures
and
so that wasn't gonna be a good idea so
what was the occasion the 17th
anniversary of her 2005 album the
emancipation of mimi first of all happy
anniversary mimi
the emancipation of mimi one of my
favorite albums ever so thank you um
what are i have a question
um what are your favorite tracks
anybody have any favorite tracks as a
matter of fact
i do it's like that i came
[Music]
you know
just to name a few that album meant a
lot to me but that isn't the only reason
the grammy winner is celebrating dj
khaled
another one yeah mariah gave a big shout
out to the fans for supporting the big
energy remix featuring lotto and dj
khaled the track samples mariah's 1995
hit fantasy
[Music]
[Applause]
celebrating number one on the digital
sales chart yay can i get a yay from the
background
[Applause]
[Music]
no it's so festive and if all that
wasn't festive enough the songbird who
shares 10 year old twins monroe and
moroccan with her ex nick cannon
welcomed her daughter to the party
okay hi
apple didn't fall far from the tree
tonight we're not twins because i have
my hair straight
but and i have my hair she has hers
curly e.t spoke to the queen of all
things holidays last year don't even get
me started about christmas and she
dished on her hit all i want for
christmas
[Music]
all i want for christmas is almost 30
years old
first of all i rebuke you because i
don't know numbers okay kevin stop
trying to age me no really honestly
it's bizarre like so when i first wrote
all i want for christmas is you the
label was like okay why don't you do a
christmas record really now like second
album like two albums in right and and
then i was like well i do love the
holidays let me try so all i want for
christmas is you was the first song i
wrote first christmas song that i ever
wrote and we just wanted to make it feel
like a modern classic so it wasn't like
oh this is this era you know what i mean
it makes me so happy because i am
festive i do love the holidays and get
this mariah is so spirited yes the
festivities
that she even has a joke where she texts
her cousin sean on st patrick's day
wishing him a happy thanksgiving and
last month instead of texting her cousin
sean she accidentally texted shawn
mendes instead i'm doing the best i can
mariah shared the 23 year old musician's
response on twitter posting this
screenshot of their text exchange where
she apologized and clarified that she
did in fact know it wasn't thanksgiving
and he replied quote that's okay i
figured it was an inside joke what do we
have to do for mariah collab because we
know you guys are fans of each other we
know she texts you now i'm not not much
i mean i i wouldn't be surprised if that
happened i love you i appreciate you we
enjoy
[Music]